i mean
three sides
thank you
is
oh
um
we have a two minute warning on the
briefing morning
thank you
uh
okay
late march
wow
it's good
uh
ugh
um
yes
okay just a couple of items for you uh
at the top
as you all know last week the president
and a bipartisan group of senators
announced a historic infrastructure deal
that would put americans back to work
with the biggest investments in our
roads and bridges since the creation
of the interstate highway system connect
every american to broadband
make unprecedented strides in climate
and clean energy leadership
eliminate all lead drinking water pipes
for the biggest investment in clean
drinking water in our history
and make the biggest investment in rail
since the creation of amtrak and no
surprise
there is a lot of interest and
excitement out there the national
governors association
as well as individual governors on both
sides of the aisle like gretchen whitmer
and charlie baker have come out and
support the us conference of mayors the
afl-cio the united steelworkers and ibew
the american society of civil engineers
numerous tribal communities the business
roundtable the rural broadband
association
the national association of counties and
many others uh the president will travel
to wisconsin
tomorrow to keep actively making the
case for this agreement
and getting it over at the finish line
and he's also going to continue
to make the case for his american
family's plan which we're also fighting
to pass
through the tooth path approach that
we've been discussing with all of
you uh also i wanted to note for all of
you that today thanks to
the president's commitment to playing
leading role in ending the pandemic
everywhere
two million doses of the pfizer vaccine
will begin to shift to peru
from the united states in 2.5 million
doses of the moderna
vaccine will shift to pakistan over the
weekend we announced
we are sending 1.5 million doses of
moderna to honduras
and over this week we'll be able to
announce more places
that the united states will be sending
our doses
finally i wanted to make sure that you
all saw that today education secretary
miguel cardona
announced the release of nearly four
billion dollars in funding to the puerto
rico department of education
including two billion dollars from the
american rescue plan to help
the island's continued recovery from the
covet 19
pandemic secretary cardone is in puerto
rico today meeting with students
government officials and education
leaders josh why don't you kick us off
great thanks jen uh senator mcconnell
today
said that president bibing should tell
speaker pelosi
and leader schumer to de-link the
partisan uh bipartisan infrastructure
bill
from any reconciliation measures does
president biden
intend to tell congressional leaders
what to do on this matter
well first let me just reiterate the
president looks forward to signing each
bill
uh he's long supported the two track
approach
and his view is that the american people
are most interested in
what we're going to do to deliver for
them how we're going to rebuild their
roads and their railways and their
bridges how we're going to make sure
they have access to broadband
that we're eliminating lead from
drinking water that's where his focus
will continue to be the case he'll make
when he's in wisconsin tomorrow
he will of course work very closely with
the leaders in congress leader schumer
speaker pelosi i know leader schumer has
noted that he plans to bring up
both the infrastructure bill and
reconciliation in july
but he'll continue to work closely with
them and other members go ahead then
secondly senator murphy of connecticut
says he's worried about
how the administration used uh
constitution's article
ii authority for the warfarin strikes in
iraq and syria
can you explain the administration's
view on
uh article 2 and kind of how it's
thinking about that matter
sure well first let me say as a matter
of domestic law
the president took this action the
airstrikes that were announced yesterday
by the department of defense
pursuant to article ii authority to
defend u.s personnel
the targeted strikes were directed at
facilities
used by iran-backed militias involved in
these ongoing attacks
for purposes including weapons storage
command logistics and unmanned aerial
vehicle operations
so uh article two the self-defense the
defense
of the united states and our interests
is our domestic justification for these
strikes announced yesterday
go ahead just follow up on that so has
president biden been in touch with house
speaker nancy pelosi or leader schumer
following his clarification that he
issued over the weekend
you're not talking about the airstrikes
you're talking about infrastructure i
was like
um we have been in touch with a range of
democrats and republicans uh including
uh leaders uh of both of the democratic
party in both houses i should say
about the path forward certainly pelosi
kind of drew a really hard line on this
i mean you just said flat out we will
not take up the bill in the house until
the senate passes the bipartisan bill
and a reconciliation bill so does the
white house feel like
they need to get pelosi on board with
this approach that president biden is
taking
i think the most effective role most
impactful role i should say
that the president thinks he can play
and i think it's safe to say that
leaders
in congress speaker pelosi senator
leader schumer
and including republicans who supported
this infrastructure bill want the
president to play
is to make the case to the american
people to the public about how
uh officials are working together to
deliver for them
and that's exactly what he's going to do
tomorrow that's exactly where his focus
will be
and certainly we'll work in close
coordination with leaders in congress
but it's up to them to determine the
sequencing of the legislation go ahead
florida does the president plan to
to go to florida has he spoken to any of
the victims families so far
well let me first give you just a little
bit of an update on what we have been
doing
uh over the last several days as you
know because we issued a readout
yesterday
the president sent his fema
administrator down to florida who had
a meeting with governor desantis and
others while he was in florida the
president spoke to him and received a
briefing afterwards
in addition we have more than 50
personnel on the ground courting closely
with state and local officials
and providing assistance fema has
deployed an incident management
assistance team
as well as building science experts
structural engineers
and geotechnical experts to support
search and rescue operations
and a mobile command center the us army
corps of engineers is also being mission
assigned to provide technical assistance
for debris removal
and two fema supported search and rescue
teams are involved in the response
to the devastating incident and
additional fema
national urban search and rescue system
teams are on alert to support personnel
already on the ground
in addition last item fema is
coordinating with the state to support
the opening of a family assistance
center and is providing communication
support
to ensure information is available in
terms of a visit by the president
we always assess we always want to
ensure
that we're not pulling from
local resources we don't want to draw
resources that are needed in the ongoing
search and rescue operations and efforts
we will remain in close contact
with officials on the ground and
certainly
if there's a trip to preview or announce
to all of you i will i will be ready to
do that
go ahead major the statement this the
president released
saturday what was the need for that and
did the president
earlier miscommunicate or did senate
republicans simply misunderstand
on the infrastructure well i will say uh
major that i think
that the statement was quite lengthy and
quite detailed in the in the president's
name
in the president's name in the
president's voice and a couple of the
points he made in there quite clearly
uh were that um when he uh when uh
last week when he had the press
conference as you all know
he understand and he indicated he
refused to sign the infrastructure bill
if it was sent to him without his
american families plan and other
priorities including
clean energy that statement upset some
republicans
who did not see the two plans as linked
as you all know
uh who are also hoping as you all know
to defeat
the families plan and do not want to see
their support for the instruct
infrastructure plan as aiding passage of
the family's plan as was noted in his
statement
he left the impression that he was
issuing a veto threat
on the very plan that he had just agreed
to which was not his intent and he
wanted to make clear
that was not his intent and in the
statement he also reiterated his
intention to move forward with
advocating for using the bully pulpit
making phone calls
working his heart out to get the
american families planned through and
his view is that you can do both and
should be able to do both and there can
be disagreement
uh even as he's pursuing the american
families
i think he made pretty clear major in
his uh in his uh statement this weekend
that that we issued this weekend that he
did not send uh
in the mat that was not the message he
intended to send and
you have said a couple of times the
president's going to tell the country
what's in it but
even those who have supported it say
we'd like to know more about it i mean
what are the details going to be
really available for those for example
who live in flint michigan or any other
city in america that does have a lead
type situation to know exactly what's
going to be spent
when it's going to be spent and the core
legislative language that
when i used to cover senator biden he
would be very much
focused on well what would you like to
know settle in i will i will share every
detail that anyone would like to know
about the package but
you're right major as you know uh it
needs to now be written
uh it needs to that is a key component
as the president said also
and as we have conveyed from here there
is work ahead uh and that is the
important work ahead is
writing this legislation moving across
the finish line i will say just because
you asked me about
um the a specific component of the
package just to give a little bit more
detail there um it will put work
we'll put americans to work replacing a
hundred percent of our nation's
lead water pipes so that every single
american child at home or in school can
turn on the faucet
and drink clean water and right now as
you may or may not know
up to 10 million homes and 400 000
schools
and child care centers get their water
from lead pipes and service lines
so that is what it will aim to address
in that specific category
life of the bill or is that a two-year
thing do you have any determination of a
timeline on that
it's an excellent question the details
are very important here it needs to all
be written into the final legislation of
the bill but the president is clearly
eager to get that done as quickly as
possible
thank you jen just another question
about infrastructure you're saying that
the president was trying to clear up
what he meant
on thursday and that it was not his
intention to issue a veto threat he said
if they don't come
to two bills together i'm not signing
real simple
so did he change his mind or did he make
i mistakes i will say peter i know that
we're quite focused sometimes on
processing here i understand that
the the process of a bill becoming a law
is important
but the president intends to sign both
pieces of legislation
into law uh he is eager to do that
looking forward to do that
as you know uh they are both moving
forward
on dual tracks in congress uh the
leaders in congress are ensuring that is
happening
okay uh something one of the advisors
said this weekend cedric richmond he
said
republicans defunded the police by not
supporting the american rescue plan but
how is it that that is an argument to be
made when the president never mentioned
needing money for police to stop a crime
wave when he was selling the american
rescue fund well the president did
mention that the american rescue plan
the
state and local funding something that
was supported by the president a lot of
democrats who
supported and voted for the bill could
help ensure
local cops were kept on the beat in
communities across the country
as you know didn't receive a single
republican vote that funding has been
used to keep
cops on the beat but at the time that
was sold as these local police
departments might have a pandemic
related budget shortfall not we need to
keep cops on the beat because there's a
crime wave
i think that any local uh department
would argue that
keeping cops on the beat to keep
communities safe when they had to
because of budget shortfalls fire police
is is something that
helped them address crime in their local
communities in local communities the
white house's argument was
the american rescue plan is going to be
1400 checks it's going to be
vaccines vaccinators uh where it's going
to put us on the path
to beating the virus not it did those
things as well
it was a pretty good bill and piece of
legislation go ahead just one more
uh this weekend gwen barry who hopes to
represent the united states as an
olympian on the hammer growing uh events
won a bronze medal at the trials and
then she turned her back
on the flag while the anthem played does
president biden think
that it's appropriate behavior for
someone who hopes to represent team usa
well uh peter i haven't spoken to the
president specifically about this
but i know he's incredibly proud to be
an american
and has great respect for the anthem and
all that it represents especially for
our men and women serving in uniform all
around the world
he would also say of course that part of
that pride in our country
means recognizing there are moments
where we are as a country haven't lived
up to our highest ideals
and it means respecting the right of
people granted to them in the
constitution to peacefully protest
go ahead someone else which goes real
quickly on the on the covet crisis
sure so you're planning a really large
party at the white house on the fourth
yeah
a party for frontline workers and men
and women who served our country yes
and uh and also the national mall will
be open but we are getting reports now
of increasing cases of delta the delta
variant um experts are now warning that
those who got the j and j vaccine might
actually need a booster shot some of
these experts have actually gotten
such booster shots themselves to guard
against the delta variant
is this too soon are you are you being
risky by
basically allowing many many people to
get to the national mall on the fourth
of july do
is there a risk that you could be in
essence doing exactly what
you know uh was was criticized by the
trump administration
creating large gatherings that are risky
let me let me first say that we have
been
our north star has been data has been
scientists
has been the advice of our medical
experts
at every point since the president took
office uh and
just a few factual details i'm not i'm
just saying
addition to you to what you conveyed the
majority of delta cases are in people
who are unvaccinated
uh we may see some vaccinated people who
test positive for cobit of course as we
know from the data
but these those people often have mild
symptoms remain out of the hospital
and the best way we continue to convey
to people across the country
to protect yourself is to get vaccinated
including and specifically
the percentage the higher percentage of
young people people under the age of 27
who are at a lower rate of vaccination
than people who are over
that age um so i would say we of course
will continue to evaluate any steps that
need to be
taken to protect the public protecting
the american people
but we have made significant progress um
and we are confident in our plans moving
forward for july 4th
is there anything that would change your
mind i mean if we see a spike over the
next few days is there any
chance that you could change the plans
or
curve it or limit it in some way i don't
especially because people who are coming
to events like this do tend to be young
people
i don't anticipate at this point our
plans changing uh we of course are
always driven by the advice of our
health and medical experts but
uh beyond that i don't anticipate that
at this point oh go ahead okay
israel yeah the president is going to be
here today um what are the plans
what plans do you have for a visit with
the new israeli government is that um
can you say a word or two about that
sure
yeah absolutely um so let me first say
on the first question you asked um we
are um
uh look we do look forward the president
looks forward to hosting
prime minister bennett soon we're
working on a date but don't have
anything to preview at this point in
time
today's visit is a chance to recognize
president rivlin's support for the
bilateral relationship
and for maintaining strong bipartisan
support for israel
the visit is also an opportunity to
highlight the deep ties and enduring
partnerships between
our nations as well as a chance for the
leaders to compare notes and consult on
both the challenges and opportunities
facing the region overall the visit will
highlight the strength of the
relationship
affirm our shared interest and security
and stability in the relate in the
region
and provide an excellent opportunity for
high level consultations on key issues
in advance of a visit we have with the
prime minister at some point
soon uh so it's also building i should
say on recent
engagements we've had at a variety of
levels secretary austin and secretary
blinken uh as well as our national
security advisor
go ahead go ahead senator romney told
jay tapper that
his reading of the president's statement
over the weekend was if the
infrastructure bill reaches his desk and
it comes alone
he will sign it is that an accurate
reading of that statement from the
president
the president looks forward to and
expects to sign each piece of
legislation
into law and he's going to work his
heart out getting both of them across
the finish line
but if he only gets if the
infrastructure bill arrives and the
reconciliation
package is not here yet no one has
clarified that yes he will
sign it so well again caitlyn i know
we're
quite focused sometimes on process in
here but uh and hypotheticals
the president's focused on selling this
package to the american people both
packages i should say that's what he'll
be doing tomorrow in wisconsin and
we'll be working closely with leaders in
congress to move both of these pieces of
legislation forward okay so the white
house is not going to say
yes he will sign the infrastructure bill
if it comes alone to his desk the
president expects to sign each piece of
legislation into law
one more question on the airstrikes if
the united states feels the need to keep
hitting
these iran-backed militia groups does
the president think that he needs to go
to congress to ask for
new authorization well the president has
talked about his desire to update
um and work with congress senator kane
and others to update
authorization parameters and legislation
i will say as i stated earlier
that uh the president is confident as is
our team in our
our justice our legal justification i
should say through article two
and our authority and our ability to
defend uh u.s security personnel which
is exactly what we did in this case
was there any consultation with uh
congress beforehand or
our allies regarding the airstrikes and
what's the next step
i mean it's if you've had the airstrikes
but
is there a reach out to iran we
completed a number of member and staff
notifications prior to taking action and
are continuing to brief members of
congress
and we're also in close touch with
partners in the region but i'm not going
to outline those from here
but specifically will there be an
outreach to iran
well uh i would say that we are uh
obviously working through we just
completed the sixth round of
negotiations uh as it relates to the
iran nuclear
uh deal uh we are i don't have a
timeline yet for when those will will
reconvene
uh but i don't have anything to preview
in terms of other outreach to iran
uh go ahead kelly i'll come to you in a
second go ahead
in terms of the timing of those
airstrikes was there any relationship to
the visit of the israeli president today
to have those
actions prior to his bill and
is there a concern in the president's
calculation there about
uh now the threats of retaliation that
are coming from some
of these militia groups and and what
posture he needs to have
given that well the president's view is
that
it was necessary appropriate and
deliberate uh action
uh these strikes designed to limit the
risk of escalation
uh we will take and he believes we will
should and will take necessary and
appropriate measures to defend u.s
personnel
partners and allies in the region uh
certainly i would say
just kind of in relation to this
question over here uh
you know we continue to believe that and
have never held back from noting
that iran is a bad actor in the region
um
and they have uh taken part in and
supported and participated in
a problematic uh extremely problematic
behavior in our view
at the same time uh we feel that uh
we're moving forward and look seeking
the opportunity to move forward on
uh negotiations to uh prevent iran from
acquiring a nuclear weapon
is in our national interest and that's
how we will evaluate but
it was not linked to a visit by the
president of israel nor was it linked to
any elections in iran either briefly on
florida
in the president's briefings about the
status of what is there
has he been given any information to
indicate that
the the chance for survivors still
exists
and does he believe there is a federal
role in examining
uh the kinds of infrastructure within
that building questions that have now
certainly come to many people's minds
after seeing what took place
sure well i i would say on your second
question that
uh there he does believe there should be
an investigation uh
and that fema a number of the resources
fema is sending to the ground
building science experts to the scene
officials from the national institutes
of standards and technology
officials from osha and the fbi they've
all been deployed to serve
surfside under their own authorities to
help
participate and provide expertise in
that in that effort so certainly we want
to
play any real constructive role we can
play with federal resources and getting
to the bottom of it and preventing it
from happening in the future
in terms of the likelihood and potential
for survivors
obviously he would refer to local
authorities on making that assessment
go ahead thanks i just wanted to follow
quickly on the airstrikes
the iraqi government issued a statement
um calling it an unacceptable violation
of their
sovereignty and national security so i'm
wondering has there been outreach to the
iraqi government
and also do you have a response to that
sort of
complaint that they've watched sure well
i would refer you to the government of
iraq on that specific question uh but i
will say that
the prime minister is a partner uh he
has a tough job
his statement called for a de-escalation
from all sides and we agree with that
but the attacks against our troops need
to stop and that is why the president
ordered the operation last night in
self-defense of our personnel
oh god yeah sorry i just wanted to ask
about this alzheimer's treatment that
was
approved earlier this month yeah um my
first question is that the president was
at all concerned by the approval process
which
seemed to overrule the advisory board
the
outside advisory report that we've
obviously learned a lot about in the
last year
um and that the approval was sort of
outside the regular fda standards for
for medicine it's a great question i
know it was last week or the week before
i haven't spoken with him about this
specifically i can i can see if i can do
that and get more back to you
i'm not sure you'll have more on it but
there's now this
question of considering the limited
efficacy and the high price of whether
the government would
impose particular restrictions on access
to it
uh due to medicare it's something that
you know if was
approved fully could have enormous costs
in the medicare system
so i'm wondering if the white house is
looking at that well let me talk to our
health team and see if there's more we
can get back to you on that go ahead
thanks
jen the senate minority leader put out a
statement today at a news conference in
which he said
the president d-linked the two bills
does the white house
take issue with that characterization or
do you agree with that is that what is
happening
i think the president is eager to sign
both pieces of legislation into law
and he is going to focus his time and
his effort on
selling the benefits of these packages
what they would do for the american
people whether it's
ensuring kids don't have lead in their
drinking water we're making sure
families have additional uh benefit from
the child tax credit extension
that's what his focus is going to be in
terms of the mechanics
and the process we're going to work
closely with leaders in congress
but he wanted to be clear that he uh
did not intend to issue a veto threat
and he remains committed to moving that
piece of legislation forward just as he
remains committed to
moving the american family's plan
forward
one other question on article two sure
what are the limits
this white house sees on the president's
article two power does it acknowledge
that there are limits
and to what extent does the president
feel he needs to yield to the article
one branch when it comes to the
authorization of course well i would say
that the president takes
legal authority and justification for
military action quite seriously
and certainly we consult our legal teams
to ensure we have that justification and
we certainly feel confident
we do uh and when there are um
attacks against our that threaten our
troops our men and women serving bravely
overseas
and responding to those certainly
qualifies as self-defense
go ahead thanks jen um when the
president
announced the bipartisan infrastructure
deal last week he said i know the senate
and the house better than most of you do
and indeed he's had long experience
in congress and in the white house so
how does a situation like this arise
where he has
to issue a statement a lengthy one
clarifying himself you all have to
reassure
people on capitol hill did he
underestimate the blowback that he was
going to get from republicans by
making the statement that he did about
you know wanting to do these bills in
town
i know there's a lot of interest in kind
of rehashing the last several days
i get it we're not going to do that
we're going to focus on
our efforts moving forward and right now
as you saw a number of republicans
go out on sunday shows yesterday and
talk about their commitment to getting
this package forward
their commitment to delivering these
benefits to the american people i just
started out talking about the broad
support from governors labor unions
others and moving this package forward
and the president's going to go out to
wisconsin and sell this package to the
american people tomorrow that's where
along those same lines that in terms of
moving forward you know you mentioned
earlier that the white house is in touch
with a range of lawmakers on capitol
hill you mentioned some of the others
before
but specifically can you talk about
outreach to liberal members of congress
are you guys in touch with the
progressive caucus there's obviously
been some concern on the left
about negotiating too much with
republicans what
reassurances if any have you given to
liberal members of congress on this
front
well absolutely we're in touch with
members of from all parts of both
you know all parts of the democratic
party a range of members in the
republican party absolutely some are the
president's directly in touch with but
our legislative team
senior members of the white house team
are absolutely engaged with
listening to conveying making the case
for why
uh there are key components of this
infrastructure package that
uh should be uh should be uh supported
by a broad range of members of our party
and i
i will note that there are a couple of
components and uh you know some
some areas where uh there hasn't been um
probably enough information out there
about the benefits in areas where
i think a number of members of the
progressive wing of the democratic party
would be excited about and support and
certainly i mentioned earlier removing
lead from drinking water
that is something that as i noted in
response to major there are 400 000
schools 10 million homes
that that could benefit millions of kids
who would benefit
from that also expansion of broadband
uh it's a national disgrace that
african-american families are nine
percent less likely to have high-speed
internet
than their white peers and latino
americans are 15
less likely it will help address that
also
access to transportation uh americans
who are trying to get to work including
communities of color that are twice as
likely to take public transit but often
have fewer
good transit options that's just one
component if you go to climate which is
an area where i think
we still are going to continue to do
more work making sure people across the
country people who care deeply about
addressing our climate crisis
know the components of what's in this
package which the president considers
a down payment not the end a down
payment so
500 000 electric vehicle charging
stations nationwide that's what this
would help support with a focus on our
highways
and rural and disadvantaged communities
it would help buy more than 35 000
electric
school buses it will include the largest
investment in clean energy transmission
in american history
will strengthen and revitalize our
natural infrastructure and it represents
the largest effort
ever to address legacy pollution these
are all areas that
a lot of people in the democratic party
are excited about historically
should be excited about we're going to
continue to make the case and make sure
we're conveying
this and the american family's plan and
the components there are what we're
going to continue to advocate for
is tomorrow's speech mainly about the
bipartisan infrastructure bill or
about the american families like how
much of tomorrow is going to be about
that deal versus the american family
tomorrow will primarily focus on
the uh infrastructure package and the
components in the infrastructure package
but
the president will absolutely also be
out there in the future
continuing to make the case for why
universal pre-k something that makes it
50 more likely that kids will graduate
from high school
should be law making sure community
college two years of it is free for
people across the country
extension of the child tax credit those
are all pieces he will be out there
advocating for in the future go ahead
david
jeff i could take you back to your
article two answers here because
they appear to be responsive to a
specific incident
or a set of incidents in which these
uavs were used against american troops
but that begs the larger question of
whether the president believes
he needs in whatever replaces the
authorization
for the use of military force something
that is specific to the
iran threat this category of threats
and similarly when you talk about having
a longer and stronger element
to the iran deal missiles
square terrorism are you also trying to
now
encompass this new use of uavs
well i would say uh on the latter
question
david uh the focus is as you've noted
and you just noted
certainly we want to look to build the
iran deal beyond
what it was in the past we've been very
clear about that and that's part of the
discussions and negotiations and the
next step would be
the seventh round of discussions and
negotiations but
i would say that as it relates to
responding to attacks
on our men and women serving or threats
i should say
to our our facilities that are in the
region
uh that we don't see that on the same
exact track
um senator murphy in his statement and i
think the reason that he had some
concern about this
i read it as less concern about the
article 2
element to what he said was that it now
seems as if we have
a low-level war underway with the
iranians because there's this sort of
constant
back and forth that an assessment that
you folks
agree with our objective david is to
de-escalate but the president is going
to reserve the option of responding when
there is a threat against
u.s interests afghanistan please go
ahead go ahead
go ahead um just on the infrastructure
celebrations senator manchin suggested
yesterday that he could support
2 trillion in a broader reconciliation
bill
does the president consider that to be a
sufficient amount of spending
well we're just at the beginning stages
of these discussions and clearly as you
noted
uh or as you alluded to i guess i should
say there's disagreement
even within the democratic party about
what the size of a reconciliation
package should look like
and as these discussions uh proceed
there will be disagreements to resolve
and there will be compromises to be made
in order to get a final package
i'm not going to do that from here the
president's uh going to continue to
advocate for
the inclusion of the american families
plan and the key components in that
package that he fails would be
instrumental
to helping the american public and he
will continue to advocate
for the components of the budget he
proposed but he also recognizes
there are important discussions
negotiations that are going to happen
between
even members of the democratic party on
this path forward select committee
that the speaker is supposed to announce
later this week has the president spoken
to her
about the membership of the committee
who he would like to see on the panel
and does he have a sense in when this
report
should be released does he think it's
important that the findings of this
select committee come out
around the anniversary for example i
think the president certainly supports
the decision
by uh the speaker to uh create the
select committee or to
launch get the process started to form
the select committee
uh in terms of the timeline of the
release of a final report i think he
would refer to her and her judgment on
that front
um go ahead in the mail so uh back to
what you said about climate even with
those policies that you mentioned there
in the bill there's a pretty sizable
protest across the street today from the
sunrise movement this is a group
that work with the campaign set policy
that's in touch with the white house but
they and people
you know a lot of their allies are
frustrated that when it came to reach a
deal it was a lot of the big climate
stuff that got paired down or left out
what is your message to
private activists who feel like wait a
second we thought that president biden
was going to be
the most aggressive president ever on
this topic why is this first high
profile bill
so whittled down well i would say i
would i would dispute the notion that
it's
uh that it doesn't do anything for
climate which some are arguing
i just outlined some key components that
would represent historic investments in
areas like
addressing the legacy pollution and
cleaning up
communities across the country
preventing that have relied on fossil
fuels and others that have been polluted
especially lower income communities
it also will take enormous steps in
addressing
investing in clean energy transmission
it will include
making sure electric vehicle buses are
part of our force across the country
uh and make sure electric uh that
purchasing electric vehicles
will at which will be a huge contributor
to uh to reducing
greenhouse gas emissions is something
that can be a reality for millions of
americans
now whether or not everyone is aware of
all those specifics that's incumbent on
us to keep conveying that communicating
it
listening and making sure people
understand that this is a down payment
and the president will continue to
advocate for
press for work for even more in the
climate as he will
uh in the reconciliation bill and
process moving forward white house want
to see a clean energy standard in that
reconciliation bill
do you think that that can fit into the
parameters of what can and can't be
included
well there's obviously a lot to be
negotiated and discussed moving forward
the president has conveyed that he would
like to see an investment in clean
energy tax credits something that would
certainly uh be an additional step
forward uh and there's
more to discuss as it relates to the
final reconciliation package and bill go
ahead michael
um you just mentioned to a colleague
that the president would like to see an
investigation
into what happened at surfside uh yeah
he supports one yep
can you expand on that just a bit would
you like to see
that uh federally run would you like to
uh see consideration of building code
changes
what should be the goal of that and who
should be in charge of that well the
goal of course is to get to the bottom
of what happened
and of course uh have it be an
instructive uh
instructive guide on on how to prevent
it from happening in the future
i just conveyed all the federal
resources we are sending down
uh to be supportive of efforts on the
ground but i don't think i have more
than it for on it than that
go ahead in the middle um housing
experts are really concerned there's
going to be a huge fallout
um if a federal moratorium is lifted
next month
and a lot of studies show that evictions
cause i'm sorry evictions make the
threat of code even worse especially
when it comes to black and brown
communities
what's the president's response to that
and can we see any type of changes
well first i would say the president
absolutely is committed to ensuring that
we
continue to provide assistance whether
it's rental assistance or assistance to
make sure that
americans who need help to stay in their
homes to stay in rental units
get the help they need the moratorium
was never meant to be permanent
obviously an extension was announced
just last week but we will continue to
look for ways uh through
federal authorities through working with
congress to ensure that we're helping
americans across the country go ahead
i just wanted to follow up on the
question previously about the july 4th
event
sure let's talk a little bit about uh
what i know i understand it's an outdoor
event but what precautions are being
taken so
will people be tested do they have to be
vaccinated are there masks even though
it's outdoors
and just more broadly um we have seen
signs that things are
going to getting back to normal a little
bit at the white house but some signs
that they aren't i mean
can you just tell us a little bit about
our all staff
here is that 100 now are visitors
allowed in i believe there's still no
tours just can you give us a sense of
where things are
sure uh anita well first our intention
was always to bring staff back and i
think we provided this publicly but
at a at a kind of a a slow pace to
ensure we were integrating people
uh back into the white house and we were
taking all the necessary precautions
i think a lot of that will be done
through the course of july uh
and into the summer uh that's our
intention in terms of the timeline for
resuming
tours uh and public and guests i'll have
to just get back to you on the specific
plans for that about the event
sure uh in terms of precautions i'll
have to check with our team and see what
the specific precautions are taking i
believe on friday's briefing you had
mentioned
that the president would be speaking
about voting rights this week at an
event
didn't see that on a schedule is can you
talk to us a little bit about what that
event is and what he's going to be
talking about sure well he has a meeting
with voting rights
advocates today and with officials
internally uh
so let me just note that first which i
think you're aware of and we're working
to determine uh when we can schedule
remarks um it could it could move in
just because of scheduling it could move
into
next week but i don't have anything to
announce quite yet he's looking forward
to addressing the public
uh as we get his final date uh
locked in i can preview it for you in
more detail go ahead
americans in the northwest are suffering
through record-breaking heat wave right
now you know what's the president's
message
on climate to those who say he's not
doing enough that there wasn't enough
bipartisan bill and can he guarantee the
public that something will be passed by
the end of this year
well first uh the i would say the
president is also meeting with governors
from western states on wednesday to
discuss
exactly the threat of these wildfires
and what we can do from a federal level
to help work in partnership
and he's been quite focused over the
last few months on ensuring we are
not just preparing and working closely
with governors who are in states that
might be impacted by hurricanes
but doing the same with states and
governors and leaders who might be
impacted by wildfires he even got a
briefing
from fema just last week i would say
again that the president is absolutely
committed to
addressing climate it is one of his the
four crises he's identified as central
to his presidency
this the components that are in the
infrastructure package are a down
payment on that but he will continue to
advocate for
fight for additional steps in the
reconciliation package
and moving forward through the course of
his presidency
um i want to ask two questions one on
policing sure and the other on boarding
photographs okay
oh police and the framework was
announced last week um
policing the doors for the justice and
policing act
but with that said uh what pieces are in
it that the white house applauds what
pieces
are out at the white house once back in
because we understand
qualified immunity may or may not be in
there some parts may be in versus other
parts
well i understand your question april
but we're going to let the negotiators
speak from to more specifics of what is
in the framework
and the next steps from their end we are
closely in touch with them
as i've noted in the past the president
will look forward to welcoming them to
the white house at some point when
appropriate um
but uh we're going to let them announce
the details of their agreement or their
framework
in the debate where it comes to
intentionality from police
when someone is killed in their hands is
he in
involved in that debate does he stand on
the side of that
do you have been involved meaning um
that piece of
is this a large uh component of the
nation
that feels that the intention should be
put into it
as well as if it just happens as they
are in police custody so both pieces
should be in
is the president weighing on one side or
the other on that case again april
we're just going to let the negotiator
speak to what's in the package and
uh what's in the framework uh at the
appropriate time when they're ready to
do that
voting rights um again i'm going back
to god face you that i asked leaning in
since the president is doing more
but is there concern if the president
leans in too much
with some of the members of the
republican members on the hill that
it could backfire on him because we've
heard that
in what way in the way that they don't
want civil rights if the president
himself with with the gravitas with the
weight of this lobby perch
if he leans in too much or it could just
backfire is that a concern
from you and from the western members of
this white house no
go ahead i just want to follow on
anita's question
most members of the press who come in
here now are vaccinated
and don't have to be tested every day is
that also the case on the staff is all
the staff vaccinated and
if you're going to come in close contact
with the president you still have to be
tested
uh yes i mean it's different for there's
different categories of people who have
regular contact with with the president
otherwise so uh some are tested twice a
week some are tested once a week as you
know when there's travel
that's a different circumstance but we
still do have staff tested regularly
here at the white house and everybody in
the staff
has been vaccinated i don't know if
every single person has been
uh but we can see if there's more
specific data on that for you go ahead
thank you the first u.s taiwan trade
talks
in five years are supposed to take place
this week
china has responded to that to the
government of beijing
calling on the united states to stop any
form of official
exchanges with taiwan how do you respond
to
the government in beijing pressuring
washington like this about
economic ties with taipei well
let me first say this is not a direct
response but let me just re
convey to you what our policy is which
is that our support for taiwan is rock
solid
taiwan is a leading democracy a major
economy and a security partner
and we will continue to strengthen our
relationship across all areas
all the areas we cooperate including on
economic issues
we're committed to the importance of the
u.s taiwan trade and investment
relationships and we will continue to
strengthen our trade relationship
with taiwan which is why we are looking
forward to the upcoming trade and
investment framework agreement council
meeting
which was recently announced we have
also been clear publicly and privately
about our growing concerns
about china's aggressions toward tyron
taiwan
and the prc has taken increasingly
coercive action to undercut democracy
in taiwan we will continue to express
our strong concerns to beijing
in that regard and also our concerns
about the prc's attempts to
intimidate others in the region go ahead
in the back
oh go ahead go ahead go ahead say yeah
um i have a quick follow-up and a
question sure on iraq i know you
exhausted all the answers but
it's okay go ahead go ahead um how do
you balance
um the white house in this case the
president's duty to protect
americans whether civilians or military
in iraq
by hitting these militias and risking
being violating the sovereignties of
countries like
like iraq for example well i think i
conveyed a little bit earlier but let me
try to try to reiterate it or say it and
it's in a different way
uh you know the president uh his view
uh he agrees i should say uh with the
prime minister's
uh comments that uh he wants to
de-escalate
that's our objective uh we don't want to
see
uh iranian proxies uh threatening
our interests in the region certainly we
would we would prefer that as not the
case
at the same time the president believes
that
uh when it is uh that we have to reserve
the right
uh to respond at a time in place of our
choosing to protect and defend our
people
that is certainly a balance that every
president of the united states needs to
strike
uh but it is one where he feels
confident that the strikes
that he announced yesterday were
necessary appropriate and
deliberate action designed to limit the
risk of escalation
my question is two yemeni prisoners have
been
approved for transfer from guantanamo
and how close is the white house to
shutting down
their prison facilities considering that
it was a press act
with president obama as you remember is
to shut down
i do remember uh i uh it is if that is
correct um i would say the department of
defense would have the
uh the best update on the timeline it
remains something the president is
certainly committed to doing and eager
to move forward on
uh does the white house think it has 10
republicans currently on board
for the infrastructure plan we
continue we'll continue to make the case
continue to convey to democrats and
republicans why this package is
something that will help their
constituents across the country but in
terms of vote counting
i will leave that to leaders in congress
has the president spoken to senator
mcconnell or does he plan to speak to
him specifically about this package
i don't have any calls with the speaker
mcconnell or speaker mcconnell i don't
have any calls with senator mcconnell to
read out
sorry it must be that time in the
briefing go ahead thank you
uh there's a report from afghanistan
that the u.s is going to
send 37 blackhawk helicopters and
a couple fixed-wing airplanes is that
germany comments on that and
just more broadly is there any concern
about the
prospects of american made weaponry
falling into the hands of the taliban as
they take over
government positions as they have been
doing and might
you know expect to do more sure it's
something we've been quite cognizant of
from
the from our early engagement here or at
least engagement of the biden
administration and before that
in terms of any reports of weapons i
would point to the department of defense
go ahead in the back hi jeff thanks for
taking my question
i wanted to ask you what the
administrator excuse me what president
biden and the white house are doing to
help
agencies achieve the goals that have
been set on climate change early in the
administration through his executive
orders
there's been quite a few tasks in those
orders that agencies have missed
deadlines on or have been delayed and i
wanted to ask what the white house is
doing to help with that
specifically agency by agency this might
be something that might be more useful
if i get you kind of a written update
about what is happening agency to agency
i can say broadly speaking that
the president conveyed to his cabinet
members
from the beginning that ensuring we are
moving forward and taking steps to
address the climate crisis and
doing that with levers we have in the
federal government whether it is
electrifying fleets in the government or
taking steps to ensure we are
being leaders uh on this front as
something that he has made a priority
but we can see if there's more of kind
of a
summarized update of what agencies are
up to to provide to all of you
go ahead and uncover vaccinations what
does the administration say to parents
who are hearing on one hand
from the nation's top doctors that
children and younger americans are more
vulnerable as these variants are
spreading
but at the same time many children can't
yet get vaccinated
yeah as a as a parent of children in
that age bracket myself
it is challenging um and what we are
continuing to convey is that
we know it's been long we know parents
are exhausted and tired but
it's important to continue to abide by
the public health guidelines which means
kids wearing masks in certain
environments not others obviously
you can look at the cdc guidelines to
see what the specifics are
obviously we can't get ahead of the fda
process for approving
vaccines i know parents like myself are
eager to vaccinate their children
some also will still have many questions
as we have seen
as the vaccine has become available for
kids who are 12 and older and that is
also part of our process of engaging
with pediatricians and others to make
sure parents can have those questions
answered so
we can't expedite the fda approval
process what we can do is continue to
provide
public health guidelines make sure
parents understand
what it means if your kid is vaccinated
or not vaccinated even if it's because
they're not eligible quite yet
and of course make sure we have
resources and supply available
if and when we reach that point in time
go ahead oh go ahead
thank you so much i'll go to both of you
okay what why don't you go in the front
and then we can go to you in the maroon
shirt yes sorry it's confusing okay go
ahead
okay thank you for taking my question i
have a great question about the tokyo
windy game
the japanese government extended the
indication to president violent foreign
still considering the great
tokyo next month uh june the president
is not planning to attend the games uh
he will certainly be
rooting for the athletes as well i am
kind of obsessed with the olympics
but that's not his we will have a
delegation
from the united states as we have
historically had but we will continue to
also convey
the public health guidelines and
guidance that we've been uh
we've been delivering out there about uh
only essential travel
thank you go ahead thanks jen i
appreciate it a couple quick questions
on iraq again
um so first of all in the past even
during the sulimani strike usually these
strikes came
in response to incidents where a u.s
service member or u.s military
contractor was killed
so it's just an indication that uh this
administration is now pursuing a more
aggressive policy on responding to
iran-backed militia
attacks in iraq and secondly was this
uh was this purely a retaliatory strike
or was it meant to actually throt
imminent hostilities beyond the saturday
herbal strike upcoming in the future
well uh let me first say that um we the
united states selected these targets
because iran-backed militias used them
to conduct at least five
one-way uav attacks against u.s
facilities in iraq
since april uh so it was in direct
response to those uh
specific uh attacks uh and
uh as i've noted before of course the
president did this in uh
in in aligned with with uh
national with domestic law and
international law as well um
he has been clear the president has been
clear that um
there will be serious consequences if
iranian leaders continue to arm
fund and train militia groups to attack
our people
and obviously we've seen i wouldn't say
i mean you
there's available information over the
last beyond the last few months over the
last
year plus as to what these attacks
looked like this was the president's
decision about how he would respond to
them i can't speak to the prior
administration
hostilities though i mean not looking
back like was it retaliatory or was
there another attack in the works that
these were intended to deter
uh it was it's we selected these targets
in response to those five attacks i just
noted
i just i think i just conveyed this
clearly as the department of defense did
okay thanks everyone
have a good afternoon
what's
what do you up